[Music]
days after causing devastation and
killing at least 67
people in the philippines typhoon
vancouver has made landfall in vietnam
ramco had already weakened when it hit
but still caused serious damage and
injured several people
picking up the pieces quite literally in
the northern vietnamese city of huey
the storm destroyed many buildings there
blowing off roofs
and uprooting trees it lost strength
since moving on from the philippines but
still
caused significant damage
the authorities prepared people for the
onslaught as the storm approached
evacuating nearly 650 000 people in
coastal areas to higher ground
famco is the latest in a series of
storms to cause disruption
and misery in vietnam at least 159
people have been killed in floods and
landslides in the last six weeks
in the philippines storm vamco has
exacted a heavy toll
with a high number of casualties
especially in the north of the country
authorities are now assessing the scale
of the damage
some communities are describing it as
the worst flooding in four decades
many villages were swamped crops
destroyed
and hundreds of thousands left without
power
as in vietnam the philippines has also
been battered relentlessly by storms
over the last two months
bamko is the eighth to hit the country
in the last eight weeks
and the 21st this year
but for all the drama of the last week
the hope in the philippines is that the
worst is over
at least for now until the next storm
hits
and joining me now is dr omero paltan
from the university of
oxford a part of dr paltan's research
includes climate change
and its impact on communities dr palton
welcome
what is causing these increasingly
devastating storms
in the region
yeah thank you very much for having me
here today so
yeah i think there's a connection with
climate change while the
direct again link has not been yet uh
quantified i think that we have to have
it cleared so
that as global temperature increase so
the ocean temperatures
so yeah and then warmer oceans are
expected to aggravate the intensity and
impacts of
tropical storms as we are seeing now uh
well i would also like to
make it clear that unfortunately the
connection between climate change and
frequency of storms is not very strong
yet
so when you say that the ocean waters
are warming
what you're essentially saying is that
storms in the future
are going to get more powerful
yeah indeed that uh that's a and that's
what climate science is telling us at
present
so we have uh yeah we were expected to
see that in the coming years
storms uh more intense but it's also
important to
to see that we would also expect to see
changes in the global water cycle
due to climate change or basically the
way that it rains
so climate models and climate science
for the region in generally agree
that the region will be expected to see
more floods
for more intense precipitation events
not just from from
from tropical storms so what i think
this has been very evident during these
last
months where we have seen where we have
seen a very intense uh
or unusually strong monsoon season
and so yeah i would also like to
express that uh climb
even though we're expected to see more
flooding people should not be surprised
if in the next years or even the next
year
we just see a monsoon season that is
relatively weak or rainfall
comes late in general i would say that
climate change
means a more variable and a more or more
unexpected
climate patterns right
in terms of these unexpected climate
patterns and
storms getting more powerful what does
this mean for people
is there any preparation that
governments and communities
can do to avoid the devastation from
these storms
yeah definitely so in general a there
should be
overall integrative strategies that look
that should look at enhancing the
resilience of not just infrastructure
infrastructure systems as traditional
dams dikes green infrastructure as in
mangroves forests etc but also
strategies to look the uh the resilience
of communities of people
so that means that people should get
used or adapted to
more of these unexpected again
water climate patterns and then at the
at a greater scale i would say that
institutions a at the government level
local or national levels
should be more prepared to face this
type of of
challenges we'll leave it there for the
time being dr
omero paltan from the university of
oxford thank you